next question today hey David how do you
feel about Planned Parenthood using the
Trump national labor relations board to
break up a potential union of some of
their support staff in Colorado okay
this is very interesting Planned
Parenthood
it is an organization often championed
by the left derided by the right because
of their involvement even as a small
portion of what they do in abortion
related services the National Labor
Relations Board is an organization also
much cheered by the left and derided by
the right because they are there to
support workers and to support
unionization we now have a sort of
intersection where Planned Parenthood of
the Rocky Mountain PPR M is using the
National Labor Relations Board which has
been modified by President Trump to be
more anti-union to crush the Union Drive
of Planned Parenthood clinic workers
being paid under 15 bucks an hour in
Colorado so what do I do I feel like a
Larry David and Curb Your Enthusiasm
that infamous moment where he's kind of
on the one hand on the other hand on the
one hand I want Planned Parenthood to be
strong and viable and able to do what it
does at the same time I don't want any
kind of oppressive anti-union activity
targeting people who are trying to
unionize at the same time what if the
people trying to unionize end up
demanding such high pay that Planned
Parenthood is no longer viable but at
the same time I don't want Planned
Parenthood an organization that I think
is doing good work participating in
anti-union activities it's almost like
my head could explode but I actually
think it's pretty damn simple I think
that the truth is that number one union
unions don't have the power in the
United States that they even even did at
one point number two there is nothing
even remotely unreasonable about the
debate demands being made by the
employees of Planned Parenthood and I
think that it is absolutely within the
rights of planned parent
to try to use the National Labor
Relations Board to prevent unionization
I think that they shouldn't do it though
I'm not saying that they're doing
anything illegal this is what
organizations can do I think
the or the leaders at Planned Parenthood
shouldn't be doing this because of what
it means and I know that it's very easy
to say that and then you go back and you
look at the details and it actually
turns out they had no choice like they
were going to be just crushed by the
demands of those activists seeking to
unionize but I think that this is a
horrible sort of coming together of two
movements that really should be working
together right the reproductive rights
movement and the labor movement are
movements that historically have worked
together in so many ways and to see them
clashing in this way is really really
disappointing but you know what there
are details that are specific to this
particular situation which I couldn't
possibly sort of comment on but big
picture I don't like the fact that this
is where it's gone and I I would like it
to be resolved in a different way but
there's this caricature in the United
States among some against who are
against unions and the caricature is the
Union bullies which just have so much
power almost no one is in a union in the
United States and particularly under the
Trump administration the National Labor
Labor Relations Board has been even
further gutted of its power so I am the
last person who's going to go out there
and say the problems are the unions and
union workers not gonna hear that here